[Music]
let me just begin by saying that there
are two sides to every story and this is
my side the right one I used to be
anonymous nothing and nonentity holily
that's your name right
yeah we've had nine classes together
since kindergarten
mmm-hmm so here it is part one Brandon
just a couple hours ago you told me you
were gay
you said I should pretend to be straight
I didn't mean with me I am tormented
every day at school just one good
imaginary fling which brings us to part
two all of Brandon good point let me be
convincing yeah what thank you I just
thought pretending to lose my virginity
would be a little more special Judy
Blume's should have prepared me for that
I know tell me what you did for know he
told me the truth I was hoping that
maybe you could do the same for me so
whether I liked it or not
I was open for business twenty percent
off to Bath and Body Works is that how
much your imaginary tryst went to you I
faked rocked your world we need to pray
for her but we also need to get her the
hell out of here no on Monday things
took a turn for the scandalous screw all
these people Oliver ironically we were
studying The Scarlet Letter this girl
named Hester Prynne has an affair with
the minister is besmirched and made to
wear read a for adulterer
perhaps you should embroider a red a on
your wardrobe I'm not proud of this but
you kind of look like a stripper a
high-end stripper for governor's or
athletes
everyone's talking about yes I know
exactly you're doing if I promise not to
tell anyone I kiss you right now
[Music]
a similar situation when I was your age
I had a horrible reputation
why because I saw a whole bunch of
people mostly guys mom there's a higher
power that will judge you for your
indecency Tom Cruise
twenty-five years of marriage you have
nothing to say I'll just say it I slept
with someone if you keep talking out of
the car you're getting a divorce yeah
Amy heard you crying in the bathroom we
all thought it was cancer Oh fine
okay why you drink let's get out of here
get out of here what are you doing later
I do there's lots of beautiful women in
this bar but I can't take my eyes off
you
it's time to go home oh it's for were W
but okay should I pull the car around
you been drinking I'll Drive to the
trade your wife cheated on you because
you lost sight of who you are as a man
which take that straw to your mouth
looks like you're sucking on it okay
you're sitting in with a supercut
haircut and you're wearing a 44 you
should be wearing 42 regular credit card
where your wallets what you gotta take
control your manhood pal he put us close
please I'm sorry is bothering you
beautiful I want to show you off to my
ex-wife [ __ ] really just
I met a girl and she is game changer
she's your soul mate right go get her
back Wow how old are you I'm in love
with her and I don't know what to do
about it
I don't know when you and I stopped
being us now when I told you that I had
to work late I really went to see the
new Twilight movie by myself but it was
so bad
for you
say garnish why we take our t-shirt
seriously it's like you're photoshopped
[Music]
[Music]
Oh God hey possum I'm sorry just you in
that chair I think I would have made a
damn fine president you would have
brought a real dignity to the office
you're welcome America
welcome to Zombieland life is about more
than just survival we were a family
dysfunctional sure but what family isn't
very what would you like little girl I
really like for you to stop calling me
little girl but you know what I would
like I don't give a [ __ ] what you it
felt so good to be on the move again
oh my god I'm so sorry hi I'm Columbus
nothing this is telling us II hey poplar
this your dad
Oh whoopsie I forgot the seatbelt wrong
oh so she knows the rules I told her
just a few of her 7300 and are there
more you're cute I like it
my sister is coming she picked up the
boy he's from Berkeley Berkeley in that
weed do you do I look like the type of
person that would have weed I'm sorry
boom ya have nothing against hippie SOT
just wanna beat the [ __ ] out of we're
gonna go get her we write it down
start talking you first
[Music]
[Music]
right oh my apologies little Elvis is it
me or just to see kind of remind you of
I don't like you at all I think you
double-parked Oh more perpendicular
parks hope we don't get it is going on
here
what hello everyone violas meaning two
options you either follow my rules or
follow my rules
capisce thank you I can do it a
different way oh that's that's fine
thank you very much
[Music]
you're fired it's Christmas yeah I see
the decorations good luck in the new
year
you
I just heard you play and I want to miss
James that we keep running into each
other maybe it means something I doubt
it yeah you could just write your own
roles you know write something that's as
interesting as you are what are you
gonna do yeah my own Club every time I
think so how are you gonna be a
revolutionary if it's such a
traditionalist you holding on to the
Past but jazz is about the future yes
maybe I'm not like a pipe dream this is
the dream
it's conflict and it's compromise it's
very very exciting
[Music]
darris queen you are mad
giving me a pass which is a monstrous
extravagance mrs. Molly we are at war we
won which is not over
we must continue oh oh I did not know
that and queenís an extraordinary person
[Music]
I can tell even if I can't see and I
heard the word fat and ugly no one but
me would dare and I did not
she's been stalked by tragedy everyone
leaves me
[Music]
I apologize for my appearance I hoped I
might be employed here by you as
something a monster for the children to
play with perhaps it is important to
make new friends in court is it not yes
stop it out you mock me I learned that
and I would rather you have become close
to Abigail she is a Viper you're jealous
you must send up again away I do not
want to bet shoot something sometimes it
is hard to remember whether you have
loaded the pellet or not
you must take control of my circumstance
always favor is a breeze that shifts
direction all the time then in an
instant you're back sleeping with a
bunch of scabrous [ __ ]
as it turns out I'm capable of much
unpleasantness
[Music]
did you look at me
[Music]
I cannot just stand by and let you
destroy me joy these funds between some
hands you do not gain I will stop
kicking
my dear friend how good to see you've
returned from hell I'm sure you shall
pass through it one day thanks for
taking him Seth oh no problem I can't
imagine what you're gonna do without
each other next year Evan told me you
didn't get into Dartmouth and you're
gonna miss each other no I don't miss
each other I'm gonna cry myself to sleep
every night me too
when I'm out party go to school boys bye
take care of those I never see no
parties or anything
Sam day was actually a crazy night for
me sucks parents for throwing this party
if you get together cocktail casual Wow
and then we went to a nightclub
you got a we got ready that sounds like
you would have loved it it's like wait
you changed your name to
McLovin hope you have a first name it
just says week love it this guy is
either gonna think here's another kid
with a fake ID or here's McLovin the 25
year old Hawaiian organ donor I am
making love in know India okay I'm gonna
need to see some identification
makes me feel young again
[Music]
ethnically was he like like pretend
forever
what's the African no he was like you
he's Jewish so we have an African Jew
wearing a hoodie tonight is our last
party as high school people you know
when you hear girls saying like oh I was
so calm I said I shouldn't sleep with
that guy we could be that mistake
[Music]
[Applause]
I love you I love you why don't we say
that every day why can't we say it more
often
I just want to go the rooftops and
scream I love my best friend Evan you're
like the coolest person that's ever
talked to me and I blew it you didn't
blow it I think maybe
[Applause]
that is bona fide badass
[Music]
every day I wake up knowing that the
more people I try to save more enemies I
will make and it's just a matter of time
before I face those more power
and I can overcome
I'm so sorry I'm late
I had a traffic thing did your traffic
jam have anything to do with being I
don't know shot at by machine guns yeah
I was implying that was implying that
very helpful you're gonna want to see
this Oscar had you under surveillance
why isn't that the question of the day
my name is Richard Parker I have
discovered what Oscorp was when to use
my research for I have a responsibility
to protect the world what about Peter
not everyone has a happy
this is bigger than you Peter
I made a choice this is my Paul
everyone has
No
well I remember the good times there
were no good times you cost us our prime
new partner a new Space Command Center
all gone because cool guy here mr. sexy
pants Brian Gilcrest blew the mission
you were going to wear this like flava
flav wears a cool can't let one's a
smallmouth down this driver a second
chance
there's someone a second chance your old
boss wants you back Hawaii our old
stomping ground Oh
Gilcrest you're back in the game I want
to introduce you to your Air Force
liaison she's a fast burner double
espresso I'm so Jack would say make that
a triple the old ex-girlfriend pause for
the memories I don't even remember why
we broke up cuz you're a workaholic who
creates work to avoid real work well I'm
still working on that you wrecked
everything and I put my life back
together in spite of you I will be an
invaluable addition to our mission
I have lone wolfed it all the way that's
who I am you're cynical I get it I know
what you're doing you're not gonna pick
my brains they're unpick effects
before it all came apart there's
greatness in this guy did you get the
girl we work together why don't you just
have what you want
do you have what you want hmm how is
woody I don't know woody doesn't
communicate see doesn't think you said a
lot actually
What did he say check out my manly let's
do it I've been working out and I'm a
little too handsome to ever see you as a
threat boy good evening and he said oh
that's actually very talkative I think
that you came back here for a reason
let's just talk about it before I
explode about tonight sir I have fun in
any of its many forms I have found that
nothing is fun your life is going to
become very very complicated
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the future isn't just something that
happens
it's a Bruegel force
is a great sense of humor that'll
steamroll you if you're not watching
anyone else like to share
how about you in the back of the glasses
sir my name is Bobby and I am an addict
you know you folks aren't here because
you're gamblers you are here because you
are terrible gambler okay Bobby
these folks don't need to stop doing
what they're doing they just need to get
better head whose they like you please
who's in hello it's Bobby Riggs I had a
great idea male chauvinist pig versus
Harry light feminist your solo feminists
right I'm a tennis player rabbits for
your woman by the way I shaved my legs
Billie Jean King already a champion of
women's rights as now the most
accessible female player of all hi I am
NOT saying that women don't belong on
the Clark who would pick up the balls
otherwise oh my god there's gonna a
single thing I don't hate it but Bobby
Riggs you know what I'm doing I'm
cooking I'm cooking I won the triple of
Wimbledon I could be pulling Jane King
don't you have the know call Bobby Tommy
Tommy so ladies what do you want
don't get me wrong I loved women in the
bedroom and in the kitchen we target
Bobby more nonsense you spell the worst
can be when you lose
I'm gonna be the best that way I can
really change things
ladies and gentlemen I'm gonna put the
trail back in chauvinism Bobby's a clown
that's how things an act for him
business sports you name it at the very
topic is a man's world when we want a
little bit of what you got that's where
you can't stand 40 million people are
watching the Battle of you've all been
waiting this day how did we end up here
this place is horrible
smells like balls we had it all you were
a movie star remember this guy used to
be dirt man I like that poster you wrote
this adaptation I did yet and you're
directing and starring in your
adaptation that's ambitious
are you afraid people will say you're
doing this play to battle the impression
that you're a washed-up comic strip
characters absolutely no that's why 20
years ago I said no to Birdman for now
you're about to destroy what's left of
your career we should have done that
reality show they offered us job you
know I'm right
there's some gnar hey so what you try to
rest a little bit
face it dad you're doing this because
you're scared to death like the rest of
us that you don't matter and you know
what you're right
you don't baby can you understand me now
sometimes I get a little mad
don't listen to me
you are a rich man let's make a comeback
that's what I'm talking about you are
[Music]
like a bad suit yes he is but he's going
out on that stage and risking everything
to do something right you gotta take it
let's go back one more time and show
them what we're capable of
there you go you [ __ ]
[Music]